Congress will vote today on a short-term
budget extension to keep the government
from shutting down tomorrow the spending
measure would keep the government
running for one week while Congress
negotiates a longer-term budget
independent senator Bernie Sanders of
Vermont is with us from Capitol Hill
ahead of that vote senator good morning
good morning or are you confident that
the US Congress will avoid a government
shutdown
well I surely hope so it would be a
disaster if the government shutdown and
I hope we do our jobs and make sure it
stays open let me ask you about this
interview that President Trump has given
to Reuters in which he warned that
there's a possibility of a quote major
major conflict with North Korea what did
you think of that well I think the
president also said that he wants to do
everything that he can to avoid that
conflict when you're talking about a
major major conflict what you're talking
about is a nuclear war obviously I think
the goal now is the work as strongly as
we can with China China is I think
receives about 80% of the exports from
North Korea are they are in a position
to tighten the screws on North Korea and
tell them that they cannot continue
their missile program or their nuclear
program but what concerns me right now I
have to tell you sitting here in the
Congress is these incredible tax breaks
that President Trump and the Republican
leadership are proposing it just seems
to me that a time of massive income and
wealth inequality the idea that we would
give three hundred and fifty three
billion dollars in tax breaks to the top
two-tenths of one percent while cutting
back on education and health care and
the needs of our children and seniors is
to be totally absurd and we've got to do
everything we can to oppose that okay
that's exactly what I wanted to ask you
the New York Times says today Trump's
plan shifts trillions to the wealthiest
it goes on to say that rich Americans
richer families and their heirs will
benefit from this can that get through
Congress well look what you have now is
a Republican leadership doing the
business of the Koch brothers the second
wealthiest family in America who spend
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
trying to electric
publicans I think that at a time when
the top one-tenth of 1% now owns as much
wealth as the bottom 90% when so many of
our people are hurting when the middle
class is shrinking the idea that you cut
programs that people desperately need to
give tax breaks to the billionaire class
is totally insane so I really do energy
I've said that before many times even
during the campaign so what can you do
about it in this Senate
well it's Congress well we can rally the
American people to say that when you had
a president who campaigns on supposedly
behalf of the working class of this
country that he's being totally
hypocritical and dishonest giving tax
breaks to billionaires it's not standing
up for the working class of this country
well the latest poll shows senator 96%
of the people that voted for him still
support him why do you think they're
sticking with him well the latest poll
also shows that he's the least popular
president in American history at this
point in his administration I think it
speaks to the fact that the Democratic
Party has not been as strong as it
should be in making it clear which side
it is on the fact that we are the only
major country on earth not to guarantee
health care to all people as a right the
fact that the middle class today has
many many millions of people are working
longer hours for low wages Democratic
Party has got to get its act together
make it clear that it is on the side of
working people and expose Trump's
hypocrisy you know tomorrow's our 100th
anniversary the 100th day of his
presidency
is there anything he's done in the last
100 days that you can look at it and say
Donald Trump you done good attaboy well
I think there are some things obviously
that he has done but I think that just
you know he does a lot of things but I
think the gist of his 100 days and what
really bothers me the most is not just
his hypocrisy of telling working
families vote for me I'm going to stand
up for you and then doing exactly the
opposite after he is elected that
hypocrisy is I think what is disturbing
to many many people here one thing that
he's done well well I think he has
talked at least about the need to
rebuild our crumbling infrastructure and
put a trillion dollars into it that is
if he is going to follow through on that
that is a very important like something
you could support legislature
if it is not in the right way absolutely
we can create up to 15 million jobs for
rebuilding our roads and bridges
mortises senator do you believe how the
president is taking us closer to war
with North Korea this is a very no this
is a very complicated and difficult
issue North Korea is an isolated
dangerous country that has nuclear
weapons working on a missile system the
goal now is to bring the world together
especially China to tell North Korea
that that economically they are not
going to survive if they continue
development of nuclear weapons and
intercontinental missile efforts
President Obama is going to speak at an
event here in New York a Wall Street
investment bank for $400,000 fee you
were critical of Hillary Clinton for
taking money like that what do you say
about President Obama making an even
larger fee look President Obama's a
friend of mine I think he as president
represented our country with integrity
and intelligence but I think at a time
when people are so frustrated with the
power of Wall Street and the big-money
interests I think it is unfortunate that
President Obama is is doing this you
know right now you have president
Trump's key economic adviser as you know
is Gary Cohn former president of Goldman
Sachs a firm that paid five billion
dollars in federal vines because of the
legal behavior Wall Street has
incredible power and I would have hoped
that the president would not have given
a speech like this are you saying if you
were offered $400,000 to give a speech
you would turn it down your climates if
Wall Street offered me that yeah I don't
want Wall Street's money even though
it's on I don't but I must tell you I
really don't have to worry about that
too much
I haven't gotten too many invitations
from a lot that help some people out
there be really ever say never senator
yes all right let us know if the phone
rings
[Laughter]
senator Sanders thank you so much for
joining us